밤이 되면 도시의 불이 꺼집니다.
그런데 지금 쿠바에서는 밤이 되기 전부터 불이 꺼집니다.
수도 하바나에서도 하루 20시간 넘게 전기가 끊기는 날이 나오고
주유소는 문을 닫고 사람들은 더위와 어둠 속에서 하루를 버팁니다.
쿠바에너지 장관은 디젤과 연료율과 사실상 바닥났다고 말했습니다.
한 나라의 전기, 교통, 식량 유통, 병원, 통신이 동시에 흔들리고 있는 겁니다.
보통 우리는 이런 장면을 경제난이라고 부릅니다.
조금 더 심각하게는 인도주의 위기라고 부르죠.
그런데 워싱턴에서는 이 장면이 조금 다르게 읽힐 수도 있습니다.
쿠바 시민들에게는 재앙이지만 미국 입장에서는
쿠바 정권이 흔들리고 있다는 신호일 수 있기 때문입니다.
그리고 어쩌면 플로리다 앞에 오랫동안 남아있던
지정학적 위험을 제거할 수 있는 기회로 보일 수도 있습니다.
오늘 우리가 주목할 이야기는 바로 이 지점입니다.
미국은 정말 쿠바를 민주화하려는 걸까요?
아니면 플로리다 앞에 놓인 지정학적 위험을
제거하려는 걸까요?
쿠바가 미국을 불편하게 만드는 이유는
쿠바가 강한 나라여서가 아닙니다.
너무 가까운 곳에 있기 때문입니다.
플로리다 남단에서 쿠바까지는
약 145km, 서울에서 대전 정도의 거리입니다.
냉전 시기 소련이 이곳에 미사일을 배치하려 했던 이유도
지금 중국과 러시아가 이곳을 그냥 지나치지 않는 이유도 같습니다.
쿠바는 작은 섬이지만 미국의 지도 위에서는
결코 작은 문제가 아닙니다.
미국은 오랫동안 쿠바를 민주주의와 인권의 언어로 설명해왔습니다.
쿠바 정권은 권위주의적이고
반체제 인사를 탄압했고
경제를 제대로 작동시키지 못했습니다.
이 비판은 틀리지 않습니다.
실제로 쿠바 시민들이 오랫동안 고통을 겪어온 것도 사실입니다.
하지만 이것만으로는 지금 미국이
왜 다시 쿠바를 강하게 압박하는지에 대한 설명이 부족합니다.
더 깊은 이유는 쿠바의 체제만이 아니라
쿠바의 위치에 있습니다.
쿠바가 공산주의 국가라서만 문제가 되는 것이 아니라
미국의 적들이 쿠바를 이용하기 너무 좋은 위치에 있기 때문에
문제가 되는 겁니다.
쿠바의 생존 방식은
늘 외부 후원자와 연결돼 있었습니다.
카스트로 혁명 이후 미국이 금수조치를 가하자
쿠바는 소련의 석유와 보조금으로 버텼습니다.
소련이 무너지자 쿠바 경제는 크게 흔들렸고
그 다음에는 베네수엘라가 새로운 후원자가 됐습니다.
쿠바는 베네수엘라의 의사와 안보 인력, 정부 인프라를 제공했고
베네수엘라는 쿠바의 원유를 제공했습니다.
그러니까 쿠바는 완전히 자립해서 버틴 나라라기보다
시대마다 후원자를 바꿔가며
버텨야 한다고 생각합니다.
좋은 나라에 가깝다는 겁니다.
그런데 지금 그 생명줄이 끊기기 시작한 겁니다.
베네수엘라의 마드로 체제를 둘러싼 미국의 압박이 커지면서
쿠바로 들어가던 원유 공급도 막혔습니다.
멕시코와 다른 공급초도 미국의 압박을 의식할 수밖에 없었죠.
러시아가 유조선을 보내서 잠시 숨통을 틔워주기는 했지만
그것은 몇 주짜리 임시 처방에 가까웠습니다.
문제는 현대 국가가 전기 위에 서 있다는 겁니다.
전기가 꺼지면 공장만 멈추는 것이 아닙니다.
냉장고도 멈추고
병원이 흔들리고
물류가 끊기고
식량 배급이 무너집니다.
그래서 쿠바의 전력난은 단순한 정전이 아닙니다.
국가 시스템이 어디까지 버틸 수 있는지를 시험하는 사건입니다.
그런데 바로 이 위기가 미국에게는 압박 카드가 되죠.
같은 정전을 쿠바 시민은 재앙으로 겪지만
워싱턴은 정권을 협상장으로 끌어낼 수 있는 기회를 읽을 수 있습니다.
그렇다면 미국은 왜 이렇게까지 쿠바를 신경 쓰는 걸까요?
답은 지도 위에 있습니다.
쿠바는 플로리다 바로 옆입니다.
미국 남부에는 중요한 군사시설과 우주발사시설,
해군기지, 공군기지들이 포진해 있습니다.
케네디 우주센터도 있고 남부사령부도 있고
여러 항공기지와 해군시설들이 있습니다.
그러니까 쿠바의 적대 세력의 감시망이 들어선다는 것은
미국 입장에서 단순한 외교 문제가 아닙니다.
미국 본토를 들여다보는 창문이 생긴다는 뜻입니다.
여기서 중국 문제가 등장합니다.
최근 몇 년 동안 미국 안보 커뮤니티는
중국이 쿠바에서 신호정보를 통해
상보 수집 능력을 키우고 있다는 의혹을 계속 제기해왔습니다.
CSIS는 쿠바 내 여러 시설이 미국과 주변 지역의 통신,
군사활동, 우주발사 관련 신호를 감시하는 데
활용될 가능성을 분석했습니다.
중국 본토에서는 할 수 없는 일을
플로리다 바로 앞에 섬에서 할 수 있게 되는 겁니다.
여기에 걸프코스트 문제까지 겹칩니다.
미국은 쉐일혁명 이후 다시 세계 최대 에너지 생산국이 됐습니다.
텍사스와 루이지애나, 걸프코스트에는
정유시설, LNG 터미널, 전략 비축류, 항만 인프라가 몰려있습니다.
미국 에너지 패권의 심장부가 이 지역에 있는 셈입니다.
그런데 쿠바는 바로 그 길목 옆에 놓여있습니다.
유럽으로 향하는 에너지 수출로
카리브해와 멕시코만의 해상교통, 미국 남부 인프라를 바라볼 수 있는 위치.
그래서 쿠바가 미국에게 단순한 이웃이 아니라는 겁니다.
그런데 최근 쿠바를 둘러싼 불안이 더 커진 사건이 하나 있습니다.
미국 언론에서 러시아와 이란이
쿠바에 300대가 넘는 군사용 드론을 제공했다는 보도가 나온 겁니다.
러시아와 이란의 드론 이야기도 이 맥락에서 같이 봐야 합니다.
쿠바가 군사용 드론을 받았다는 보도만 보면
마치 미국 본토가 곧바로 위협받는 것처럼 보일 수도 있습니다.
쿠바가 드론을 찾는다는 것은 쿠바가 강해졌다는 뜻이 아닙니다.
오히려 쿠바 정권이 자신이 얼마나 약한지를 알고 있다는 뜻입니다.
미국의 압박이 강해지고 에너지 생명줄이 끊기고
정권 교체 이야기가 공개적으로 나오는 상황에서
쿠바는 비대칭 억제 수단을 찾습니다.
약한 정권은 무너질까 봐 드론을 찾고
강대국은 그 드론을 개입의 명분으로 삼을 수 있습니다.
이 지점에서 쿠바 문제는 더 위험해집니다.
쿠바가 실제로 미국을 공격할 능력이 충분해서가 아닙니다.
쿠바가 약하기 때문에 위험해지는 겁니다.
약한 정권은 생존을 위해 외부 세력에 더 기대고
외부 세력은 그 약점을 이용해 미국 앞마당에 발을 들입니다.
그러면 미국은 다시 그 움직임을 제거해야 한다고 판단합니다.
악순환이 시작됩니다.
최근 CIA 국장이 쿠바를 방문해 고위 인사들과 만났다는 보도도
같은 맥락에서 읽을 수 있습니다.
이것은 단순한 외교 접촉이 아니라
미국이 쿠바 내부의 실질 권력과 협상하려는 신호일 수 있습니다.
여기서 중요한 것은 쿠바 대통령 디아스케넬만이 아닙니다.
쿠바의 권력 구조는 훨씬 복잡합니다.
라울 카스트로, 군부, 그리고 군사나 경제복합체인 가해사가 있습니다.
쿠바에서 대통령을 바꾸는 것은 간판을 바꾸는 일일 수 있습니다.
하지만 진짜 문은
군부와 돈줄을 쥔 사람들에게 있습니다.
가해사는 호텔, 금융, 관광, 외화 수입 등
쿠바 경제의 핵심 영역을 장악해온 것으로 알려져 있습니다.
미국이 정말 쿠바를 바꾸려 한다면
공식 대통령보다 이 군부 경제 권력을 움직여야 합니다.
그래서 미국의 목표는 쿠바의 완전한 개방이라기보다
쿠바의 방향전환일 가능성이 큽니다.
반미 전초기지에서 친미 완충지대로 바꾸는 것,
중국과 러시아가 미국을 들여다보는 창문을 닫는 것,
플로리다 앞에 전략적 불안을 제거하는 것,
이것이 민주주의라는 언어 뒤에 숨어있는 더 차가운 계산일 수 있습니다.
물론 여기에는 강한 반론이 있습니다.
그렇다면 쿠바 독재정권을 그냥 두자는 말인가?
쿠바 정권은 시민을 억압했고 경제를 망가뜨렸고
수많은 쿠바인들이 나라를 떠나게 만들었습니다.
중국과 러시아의 영향력이 플로리다 앞까지 들어오는 것도
미국 입장에서는 받아들이기 어렵습니다.
그러니 미국이 압박하는 것 자체가 잘못이라고 말하기도 어렵습니다.
문제는 압박 자체가 아닙니다.
문제는 무엇을 목표로 압박하느냐입니다.
민주화를 목표로 한다면 시민사회, 제도, 식량, 에너지, 행정재건이 중심이어야 합니다.
하지만 지정학적 위험제거가 목표라면
쿠바 시민의 자유보다 쿠바의 방향과 위치가 먼저 보입니다.
정권의 돈줄을 겨냥하는 압박과 사회 전체의 전기를 꺼버리는 압박은 다릅니다.
전전은 권력을 흔들 수 있지만
후자는 시민의 삶을 먼저 무너뜨립니다.
쿠바 문제를 민주주의 대 독재로만 보면 절반만 보게 됩니다.
미국이 쿠바를 다시 압박하는 가장 깊은 이유는
쿠바가 공산주의 국가라서 만이 아닙니다.
쿠바가 플로리다 앞에 있고 걸프코스트 옆에 있고
중국과 러시아가 미국을 들여다볼 수 있는 자리에 있기 때문입니다.
결국 쿠바의 운명은 이념보다 위치가 결정해 왔습니다.
냉전때도 그랬고 지금도 그렇습니다.
쿠바 시민들은 전기가 들어오기를 기다리지만 강대국들은 지도를 펼쳐놓고 계산합니다.
어느 악로가 위치한가?
어느 시설이 감청될 수 있는지?
어느 정권이 누구 편에 설 것인지?
쿠바의 비극은 낡은 이념에만 갇혀있는 것이 아닙니다.
더 큰 비극은 그 섬의 위치가 너무나도 중요해서
쿠바인들의 삶보다 강대국의 지도가 먼저 펼쳐진다는 데 있습니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.
시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.